so long and go we will talk about robust
optimization in the machine thank you
it's great to be here it's been a long
day I'm sure so I have a lot of formula
to blast to you so what I do is just a
quick introduction to robust
optimization and I apologize if you know
a lot of material there it's going to be
basic but at least giving you the basic
arguments of that field and then see if
has relevance to machine learning and I
must come with a warning there it's what
I'm going to present is not like a fully
tested thing except in some cases but so
it's just a possibility and so in robust
optimization basically we start with a
problem which generally it's better if
that problem is pretty simple like a
convex optimization problem not to say
that convex optimization problems are
always simple but let's say you start
with a linear program that describes the
favorite decision problem and there we
revisit this and say well what is
happening if for example parts of the
coefficients in that optimization
problem think of the cost vector in a
linear programming problem what if they
are uncertain I don't really know them
up to noise or I I'm using the nominal
problem which is here to come up with a
solution X it's a vector of decisions
but actually when I go and implement
that decision I don't actually implement
X exactly so two examples
imagine you're designing a circuit for
such problems at some level of the
hierarchy of the circuits there is like
popular models or quadratic programs of
large scale and the design vector might
be you know the width
of different connections between
transistors that wit is the result of a
printing mechanism there's noise
associated with this even though you
think you computed the solution
optimally let's say to 12 decimals
you're never going to implement those
and so there's been a study on open
source you know real life industrial
optimization problems where somebody has
revisited those problems and just
included a tiny bit of implementation
error in relative scale and what they
found is that many of those problems not
only the change would lead to suboptimal
et which is natural but complete in
feasibility so by just a tiny point or
1% relative error you obtain something
that's not even feasible let alone
optimal so that is one example another
example is you know in when you're doing
financial trading you solve again a
quadratic program is maybe the most
popular way to make these decisions on
an automated fashion and sometimes when
you're predicated to buy or sell these
many shares of these many assets then
actually as you start buying maybe the
price evolves and you don't get the
price you thought you would and
therefore you don't get the same amount
of shares maybe and so those errors are
prevalent in any optimization problems
that I seen in practice so one way to
address this and there are other ways
which I'll refer to is to consider
so-called robust counterpart where you
revisit the nominal problem and now
you're going to do a more fine-grained
analysis where you allow your functions
that appear in the problem the optimal
optimal the the cost function and the
constraints they are noun depend on new
set of variables that are Nord is not
decision variables that
not us for us to decide rather there
let's say let's so-called nature
it's an adversary and what that
adversary does it is fighting to serve
you a higher cost function and it also
will work to make your constraints not
visible essentially then what you are
going to do is to make a decision so
that irrespective of what nature does
you want to be sure that the constraints
are satisfied and as well
based on those constraints on your
decision X you're going to minimize the
worst case among possible choices that
nature has of this cost function so this
is very generous and I reassure you in
Chris's case you wondered it's
completely uncrackable in general so
even though the original problem is
convex even simple versions of this lead
to intractable problem however there's
classes of problems like this that have
practical value and our tractable so
I'll go into this let me in ffice eyes
that here you're modeling assumption is
the uncertainty set that's associated
with the adversary once you have that in
place and you know all these functions
at least you can write down the problem
so not as well that if this problem this
one is convex then irrespective of what
the actual dependence of the functions
on the uncertainty is even if that
dependence is not convex but as long as
those functions are convex in X for
every uncertainty you then these
problems also this problem is also
convex alright so there's a lot of
variance on that but before I jump into
those more advanced models let me say
that this here is just one paradigm to
address and certain team decision-making
the more classical paradigm you can call
it scenario based basically if you don't
know what the world has in store you
just cook a number of scenario
you then deal with those and one way is
to simply think of you the set as a
finite set of different scenario and
this is one way to deal with the
scenario approach when you is finite
however other authors have simply
proposed to maybe not look at the worst
case but the just the average across the
scenarios okay so there's many many ways
to address this and I'm just here diving
into a particular approach this
robustness doesn't have to be at the
first level basically here the
uncertainty is what we're fighting
against and it has prescribed an
uncertainty set that's where the
uncertainty can be and often that the
uncertainty can do whatever it wants in
some cases you want to further say that
the uncertainty is actually random and
that leads to a stochastic programming
formulation in between stochastic
programming where u is completely random
with a known distribution and this you
have in the middle something called
distributed shonali robust I it's ugly
to say distributionally robust
optimization what does that mean here is
an example here I'm assuming the
uncertainty follows a distribution I'm
taking let's say to simplify the
expected cost and I'm trying to minimize
this oh but wait I don't know the
distribution with high precision so now
I'm choosing to do a rob
distributionally robust approach where I
let P the distribution lie in a given
set now this is pretty practical because
in practice unless you know for sure
that your distribution has this
is a Gaussian with that mean and that
covariance for example before you know
that most likely in practice you want to
estimate the distribution by some
maximum likelihood for example and you
will never get to a point where you
measure enough data and then you are
confident that this is the distribution
in most cases you barely know what the
distribution is this model here is a
bland be that you know addresses the
problem partly with a stochastic
programming approach but on top of it
there's a layer that says that the
underlying distribution is not well
known so again I'm just talking here
about problems that are completely
unsolvable it's nice to write them but
unless you make strong assumptions these
are not solvable so there are cases
where it's very easy to solve and one of
them is as I say here is to start with a
linear program okay and revisit the
linear program let's say that the
coefficient vectors here in in the
constraints they're actually not
well-known and you're saying well
they're not well known within euclidean
bolts so what you know now is not AI as
in the nominal model but you know a hat
that's in an estimate and then radius
Rho that tells you that the estimate is
noisy
okay the Rho could be thought of as
depending on the index I if you wish for
more but basically this is a situation
and so how you address this how are you
take into account the knowledge or the
lack of knowledge about AI which is
partial because you know a guess and the
radius of uncertainty well what you do
is you set up your optimization again
I'm not considering the case where the
cost vector itself is unknown but you
could approach it the same way and here
you're revisiting the constraints you're
adding I want the constraints not to be
true in average more than that I want to
make sure that
they are satisfied even if I perturb the
vector the coefficient vector by a
certain amount and so this problem can
be readily processed because this
constraint here when this is actually a
sphere or even an ellipse or something
like simple like that you can process
this very simply and I'll write the
formula in the case when the uncertainty
set is is really a Euclidean ball so if
you assume this let's say 1 here then
this problem has constraints that really
involved
this is work working better a little bit
so what you get is a constraint like
this so now the problem if you stack it
together those are known the constraints
of the problem as expected they have no
uncertainty anymore in it because we
just solved this condition by hand in
closed form and what it says is that
well if you want to buy robustness you
should certainly make sure that the in
average the constraint is satisfied but
you need to pay a premium that's due to
the risk in this not being the correct
value and that's your risk premium and
if you think of AI you know more like a
random variable with Gaussian
perturbations you could think of this as
the standard deviation of the of this
thing if AI was random Gaussian centered
in a hat and having a covariance matrix
Rho times identity then this would be
nothing else than the variance so the
standard deviation sorry all right
this problem is not like its nominal
counterpart it's not a linear program
it's actually a second-order cone
program meaning that it involves you
know Euclidian norm less than something
where didn't inside the norm and outside
you only seen linear functions and so
these problems are can be solved at
scale especially this one now you might
wonder well is this applied have people
applied that thing and yes you will see
later that even in machine learning
people have applied a similar thing
quite extensively so now what I want to
do I've just made a little bit overview
and what I would like to do is explore
things that are more at
and one of the things that is quite
interesting to me is the notion of
recourse which is a standard thing in
decision-making under uncertainty when
you apply to robustness it leads to
interesting perspectives and this is
much less has been much less applied in
practice so what is the idea the idea is
when I teach this part of the of the
material to my students I take the
example of driving of course they never
drunk drive like me so they don't know
what I'm talking about but basically I
tell them look you know when you go and
you drive through fog there's two ways
you could do you know that there's
uncertainty in where the boundaries of
the road is so you could take a safe
approach let's call it a robust approach
where you sit in the middle you hope
that there's nobody else coming your way
and well if you have an estimate of
where the road is you can just take that
estimate in your mind and then hopefully
you're not a fantasy yeah meaning you
can visualize something then once you
have a model of where the road is you
can just close your eyes now it just
follow your your model and that would be
essentially what you know essentially a
robust approach would do you build a
model you take a decision here and now
and you just stick with it okay it
sounds crazy to you of course it is but
in fact people do even Wilder thing they
just have an estimate of where the road
is and then they close their eyes not
even taking into account the fact that
they might be wrong okay so robust
optimization is a little more prudent
because it takes into account well I
might be wrong okay all right where do I
want to come to this what I want to
mention is that in fact people open
their eyes meaning that there is a
feedback that allows them to learn as
they go where the boundaries are okay
how can you apply the same paradigm in
decision-making
well that's called recourse or feedback
if you come from
control systems theory it's called
feedback so how can you apply feedback
when you have here a process that
perturbs this problem and that is
dynamic so essentially let's say to
simplify that only this term is
uncertain and you might wonder well does
that cover realistic situation
I'll cover I'll give you an example
imagine you're trying to manage
electricity you know you have a factory
it's called a cogeneration plant it
generates heat and power for let's say a
thousand homes this plants like this all
over the world maybe you know that
all-time Pink Floyd LP they had a
factory which was that the a plant like
that anyways so now the B part
represents essentially if you allow me
to change this to a bigger than
basically X is how you produce stuff is
this heater what is the level and so and
so forth
a is the production the way how it
transforms it into actual energy and B
might be a vector that overt contains
over time how much you produce now that
B vector is the demand
you must produce ax bigger than B means
you must produce more than what is asked
for and once you establish that
constraint you must minimize cost so
that's a very reasonable and practical
thing such a problem appears everywhere
where you want to minimize your cost to
operate an some kind of resource
generating plant and so if the in in
real life you don't know what the demand
you don't know how much heat people will
want tomorrow and you can see that same
as the car with the fog if you knew
better
then you do better but you don't know
better but maybe you can exploit the
fact that as you go you discover what
people want our on an hourly basis okay
so that's you writing
through a street with fog and as you go
you know where the boundary of the road
is so what we're assuming now is that
the B part is subject to uncertainty and
notice I use a fine uncertainty I this
is an assumption of the model and
further I think I know that the
uncertainty lies in a given set how do I
come up with this model of uncertainty
that's a interesting machinery problem
that not many people look at but it's
very interesting imagine a time series
this contains let's say 24 hour worth of
that time series is a snippet you're
trying to estimate that but you want the
intervals of confidence or something
more sophisticated okay in any case
let's assume you come up with that model
and now let's take a decision well a
fully robust decision would be here and
now I decide what I will produce based
on mine certainty and that's it
instead I can use feedback because I
know as I go the certainty is revealed
to me at you know one hour from now I
will know what users wanted for that
hour because time flies okay if you're
doing a price or a trading mechanism yes
this you is uncertain but it is fixed
it's not something that changes with
time anymore as we get it okay
we assume that let's think of this as as
be the demand we assume that it's
uncertain but there is an information
flow at some point you will know what B
3 the third component of B is at the
third hour you will know it it does the
uncertainty model doesn't change yes
yeah you're referring to learning them
certainty as you go no this is not as
fancy yes and so here we're going to
make an assumption which is akin to
linear feedback in feedback control
where we say since this u vector is
uncertain now but as you go it will be
given to you let's take a decision that
finally depends on it and how much what
are the coefficients that's containing a
matrix X and the matrix X will have
structure because if u 1 u 2 u 3
corresponds to three points in time you
don't want your decision at time one to
be a function of what happens at time
three because you don't know time three
yet okay so usually that implies X is
like lower triangular or something like
that and once you put these two together
you can write a new problem where now
you can see that your decision itself
hasn't certainty in it but of course it
will be implementable as you go because
there is this causality that we built in
made in making sure that X of u depends
only on the parts of you that you know
at the relevant time so this problem is
again a robust
optimization problem that sometimes you
can readily process typically since X
and B are affine in you you know we can
process it exactly the same way with
similar techniques and this allows you
to get a much
better solution alright any questions
alright so this is the formula I told
you I would bombard you with formula
here's a bomb and so basically what it
looks like it's a much bigger problem
now because you have to carry the two
types of decision vectors one is
essentially what you would do if there
was no uncertainty and the other is how
you are going to adapt your solution as
the uncertainty is revealed to but in
the end is still an LP okay so these
problems are applied in some corner
areas I've never seen them applied in a
machine learning context I only saw them
applied in a actually a finance context
there is very interesting with follow-up
work on that's a good catch yeah yeah
yeah the problem is convex definitely I
don't know I I think I was maximizing
before
how do we get to decide when we get to
make the second action or this is just
part of the modeling that this kind of
get is handed to us that you get to make
it a sequential decision right let me
give you an example I think it's an
interesting because one of my objectives
today was to okay the previous part with
is free you know classical but I I'm
really I like this these things I think
they are interesting and not applied as
they should but basically imagine that
you want to fly from San Francisco to
JFK okay so someone tells you that here
there might be a storm okay so if there
is a storm you need to go over it
if there is no storm then then you know
you can just go like this okay so what a
fully optimistic person would do would
be just to help with the storm I'm just
gonna take it and if there is something
wrong I I will let's say you learn about
whether or not the storm is there at
this point then you can decide to go
here if the storm is there or to go
straight if not so that's your recourse
point that's when the uncertainty is
revealed to you and you can see that if
you are that this mechanism that I just
outlined is one of these recourse things
that you go here and then you adapt your
decision based on the information that
you didn't have before this guy here is
a fully robust solution doesn't adapt to
anything it's super conservative
it just takes into account all the
worst-case and therefore it loses big
time if the green is in place and it
kind of still loses with the red maybe
or maybe not it's not so clear depends
on the geometry so what the affine thing
does is to say well maybe there's a
third way that there is a
an intermediate angle that then allow me
to maybe make a better trade off that
mean you know will will be better in
average or some kind of other situation
that's a dynamic program that you can
adapt this to dynamic and I'm gonna talk
about it actually that's a dynamic
program yeah but basically the notion of
recourse is is cons or the model should
come out of the situation is usually
very simple obvious that let's say
you're making it a price decision you're
buying shares and know about price
tomorrow next day like a week from now
then you know that you don't know about
any price today but you know that in
today's you know the price of that day
so it's strange but you can exploit that
now to devise a plan it's planning to
replan yes it's a min max min max you
know it's it's exactly like dynamic
program to tell you the truth it this is
mr. I mean this is not like okay so
obvious you know it so maybe that's one
of the reasons not so applied but it's
it really actually can be really
powerful I just want to finish my
overview in terms of you know variations
on robust optimization where for example
you assume some stochastic uncertainty
so this is the notion of chance
constraints and leads to
distributionally robust optimization let
me start with just a simple single
constraint and I revisit that constraint
by telling you a it's random and I give
you the distribution
if I give you the distribution in some
cases let's say when the distribution is
Gaussian you can process this condition
in an effective way
what do I mean this condition for off
first really says that you're hoping to
make a decision X so that this
constraint is satisfied with high
probability very natural now if you
don't know the distribution I don't even
know how to write this it does no
meaning to me but if I do know it
sometimes I can process this in a very
effective way and I end up with a model
that closely resembles what I just
erased before where I had here a nominal
value that corresponds in this caution
case to the expected value of the
distribution that the the mean of the
distribution gamma is going to be the
covariance matrix of the distribution
and therefore this is nothing else than
the standard deviation of this what is
this number it's some kind of number
that depends you know complicated but
tabulated way on how aggressive do you
want this constraint to be satisfied
what is the probability you want if you
want a very high probability then
epsilon will be very close to zero and
this going to go up to infinity okay now
you can notice how similar disease to a
completely robust model with knowing
certain distributions whatsoever and you
can see a big it is essentially what
we've seen before when if you had the
intention to try to enforce a constraint
like this and I tell you a is only known
to be in some kind of ellipsoid whose
characteristics closely resemble those
of a Gaussian like if this is your
condition of your level of uncertainty
gamma is a positive definite matrix then
this is the same as a transpose hat X
Plus gamma 1/2 X less than B ok so this
is very similar and what this is exactly
the same as is when you you have this
condition here then you have your Kappa
there in other words what I'm trying to
say is that different assumptions one is
stochastic the other is fully
deterministic they lead to the same
constraint in the end now you might say
well you know Gaussian distributions is
super not realistic what if I don't know
what the distribution is exactly so that
is the robust distribution area and
there's a great many results one of them
for example based on simple chebyshev
bounds would tell you if you want to
enforce this but you don't know the
distribution except for its first and
second moment basically I give you the
mean and the covariance but I'm not
telling you it's a Gaussian it could be
anything with that mean and that
covariance then to enforce this
irrespective of what the distribution is
with those moments then you simply have
to write something like this and this
term now is a very simple expression and
I don't remember it but it's it all this
is based on chebychev of course it's
multivariate trebuchet so this here is
like a template that corresponds to many
different models they all converge to
the same kind of constraint
there there is but I'm not very familiar
with them most of what I know has to do
with moment bounce that there are other
qualitative bounds like you can say
unimodality or you can say you know I
know some stuff about the
moment-generating function or there's a
lot of things now when it comes to the
sampling thing there's a lot of
literature as well in fact one of the
main proponents of this work is visiting
now so professor Caliph Yura
he's worked on with Marco campi on this
where you use sample then you get some
estimate and yeah
so this here can be brought to more
complicated constraints and I think I
will not dive too much in this but
basically if you like semi definite
programming it's a nice area because you
have semi definite programming
everywhere all right so here's an
example sometimes you want to make sure
that the uncertainty appear ok let me
skip let me I want to skip I just want
to briefly voc dynamic programming as a
closing and then I'll go more into
supervised learning and and machine
learning so basically in dynamic
programming
okay there's many hurdles applying
dynamic programming in practice the
dimensionality is one of them this is
not addressing it it's addressing
another curse which is as nasty the
curse is what is that most dynamic
programming problems they start with the
assumption that you know perfectly the
transition matrices and think about it
this is really a dynamic process so
you're compounding the errors as you go
if you applied bellman recursion so this
is bellman recursion and it involves you
know basically a value function at time
instant a state an action this is very
classical this is a classical bellman
recursion and the question is how can
you make it robust but what does that
mean to make it robust you have first to
establish what is nature allowed to do
against you in that problem well let's
assume that nature is gonna pick
transition probabilities these this
vector describes at time T under a
certain action where what is the the
distribution okay so it's a probability
vector and if you don't know it exactly
what you do do here we're back to these
problems where the nature and U is a
play a dynamic game so basically
you play nature picks away to perturb
the transition you play nature picks at
each time instant so in fact if you look
at this finite horizon then you're doing
min max min max min max the max is the
player of nature who tries to mess with
your transition matrices and you are
taking the decisions so maybe you have
guessed it but after a little bit of
theory you can show that the robust
counterpart to this is just to put a max
there where the max is taken over those
transitions so this is the robust
bellman recursion it solves you know a
min Max min max problem and it's very
simple at each step of the recursion to
take into account in certainty in the
transition you need to first solve a
little optimization problem and then
apply your recursion now that problem
under realistic assumption about the
uncertainty on the transition is very
simple to solve in fact this bellman
recursion is not more costly than the
original one under these assumptions yes
nature picks it doesn't pick the
transition matrix once and for all and
you stick with it it's time varying
that's a very big assumption you would
say you give a lot of leeway to nature
so one model of uncertainty on a
distribution could be you know you use
kullback-leibler distance to measure how
far you are to a given distribution and
based on that then you just have to
solve a a little bit a little bit a
little optimization problem involving
maximizing a scalar product of a
variable P that's constrained in that
set that can be done by that bisection
very quickly so here this is an example
that I was giving you the example before
you know going from origin to
destination and you have now a
stochastic obstacle what is the
assumption when
in classical dynamic programming you're
assuming that this guy which is a random
obstacle has a known probability of
being there or not it's known as fixed
that's it that's your model and you run
with it but if now it starts being time
varying and moving about then in fact
you can do very poorly you can do much
poorly in fact with respect to a
conservative strategy this is the cost
of the strategy meaning just bypass the
obstacle even if it's there or not you
don't care just bypass it so you can see
that if nature is really aggressive and
perturbing seriously your estimate of
how likely is that obstacle to be there
then you can be completely misled and so
a robust strategy in on the opposite
will never be less optimal than the
actual conservative strategy now you
might think of this gap you know this is
really where it makes sense to apply
some kind of scheme like this and again
I have seen this applied in some context
but maybe there could be more interest
all right any questions at this point so
I know it's been a long day so I you
know there is this last part which is
called theory I am Not sure I'm gonna go
into it but I'd like at least to make
the connection between that body of work
and machine learning and you will be
surprised to look at the fact that many
of the current models can be interpreted
that way with the aim of robustness so
here is a classical supervised learning
problem W might contain classifier
coefficients L is a loss function X is a
matrix whose columns contain data points
and discovers for example the infamous
least squares problem
which involves a loss function having a
Y vector as a response so this is your
archetypal machine learning problem in a
supervised case and so very in practice
you almost never apply this you always
add penalty okay and I'm going to put
this in the perspective of robustness
the goal being can you use your
knowledge potential knowledge about how
noisy are the entries of X to designing
the right penalty for that okay so
that's the goal so let's say for example
support vector machine very simple has a
loss function here that involves data
points Z okay
I call them Z because later I'm gonna
say that I don't know this they are not
data
they're just uncertain so for example I
could assume that these perturb by some
matrix and let's make an assumption
about what that matrix look like I don't
want to make the assumption I know that
matrix so for example I could assume
that every column every data point is
perturbed by a sphere so what it boils
down to is is a situation like this in
the SVM case
so you have here points in a possibly
high dimensional space this is two
dimensions and you have some labels so
you have points that are circles and
others that are crosses and you want to
separate them a robust model what it
would try to do is to say we will wait
maybe you don't really know where the
points are assume that you only know
that there are in circles of a certain
radius then what can you do
well you are going to now separate the
circles that's what the robust
optimization framework would lead you to
do and so if you do that in this problem
here and instead of trying to minimize
over known data points you minimize the
worst case loss then you end up
penalizing in a strange way your loss
function using Euclidean norm
what's the geometry of this is basically
this basically if I fix the radius of
uncertainty it will appear in a special
way you know as you know kind of
Euclidean norm penalty and basically
what it tries to do is to separate the
spheres as opposed to just separating
the points interestingly enough when the
points are separable like this and you
start doing this little game where you
are going to inflate the old circles at
the same rate at some point you can see
that if i inflate the balls too much
then I can't separate the spheres so
there's a limit after which I will not
be able to separate the spheres and of
course my drawing doesn't give justice
so let me cheat and add the points here
at a point there so you can see that
there is a actually a unique separator
that is the maximum margin it's the most
robust so maximum margin classifiers are
those which are the most robust with
this
particular and certainty model so you
can see here a connection with an
earlier approach which comes from
totally different reasoning and this
reasoning leads to more or less the same
of course it's there's a little detail
here there's no square it's inside the
mag and so on but the geometry coin
sides in this separable case now you can
play with so again this is the classical
as VM this is this model predicated on
Euclidean norm and certainty they're
very similar in fact they're equivalent
when data is separable now you can play
with okay no I want to choose I know
that my data points are inside these
confidence intervals
I don't want make the assumption that
they're the vectors are in a sphere
they're in a box okay now the theory
applies as well you end up with l1 norm
and this drawing here tries to convey
the idea you know if you're familiar
with the l1 norm appearing all the time
as a specifier penalty it makes the
classifier sparse with a lot of zeros
why is that or there's a lot of reasons
for that but maybe an intuition could be
think about this little game where I was
inflating the spheres until separation
was not even possible now I'm going to
inflate squares and because the squares
they're like parallel to the axis okay
this is just appealing to your intuition
it will tend to make the classifier
vector which is embodied by in a hyper
plane parallel to the axis parallel to
the axis mean sparse okay so here you
have an explanation where you see only
one dimension in the feature space
actually plays a role in separating the
data of course this is just appealing to
your intuition nothing is rigorous there
how can you generalize it to high
dimension I don't know
just to give you an explanation as to
why l1 norm might lead to sparsity so
what this whole theme is about is to say
if you know more about your data than
just what the data is if you have a
notion of uncertainty around your data
by all means you should exploit it to
design the uncertainty to weight it so
for example this is a model where we for
example you could argue that you have a
your model is that at most and a certain
fixed number at most K points or
perturbed okay so that's a model that
actually appears in applications another
theme that goes along these lines is to
to work with thresholding and robustness
so for example you might want to so the
way presented it originally robust
optimization is a fight against nature
it's an adversary you don't know what it
does it has limited power and you fight
against it but sometimes you might want
to put in noise inside the data why
because maybe you wanna spar safai the
data for example you could say my data
I'm going to and there's a typo here I
I'm sorry what I meant here is simply to
say suppose you have a large dance
matrix but a lot of entries are small
you might want to make these entries 0
and then run with that data set it's a
modification of the data set you put in
that noise you can take that into
account and in fact what does that buy
you well it buys you to work instead of
with a dance matrix with a very sparse
matrix okay so I won't go into those and
this is just a fun little
New Times did a set where we're trying
to essentially take a keyword and find
neighbors and to do that we use
predictive machine learning what I mean
by this we're trying to identify what
other words are predictive of the
appearance of that word
here's talk and using sparse
optimization like you know sparse
machine learning you can identify just a
few words and so we are able to run this
even though it's a very large thing
because we threshold but we take into
account the threshold thing okay I will
not go more into those because I will
not just touch on the theory but before
I do so are there any questions
so where does the first two examples or
the examples at where the data is insert
thank you yeah yeah yeah but here it's
different here you're you're you're
putting in the noise so for example
another example of this approach is this
it's very common to serve that a lot of
let's let's take this yes actually
coming from stochastic optimization
begin with right we the whole thing in
machine learning what you're really
doing is to cast optimization in the
place of a sample average approximation
independent so in some sense you are
doing is robust ah it's hard we hear
what we do you're adding the robust is
just explicitly on the data generating
process right right I'm yeah I yeah it's
something I don't fully understand what
you yeah they have a certain so for
example is very typical to observe let's
say you do this right the elastic net I
don't like squares so I don't put
squares you will see why X here is a
matrix comes from data even that data
that I mentioned you know the New York
Times data you know it has very low rank
this is a data set that has you know
it's it's a big it's a big day I mean
not super big but it's pretty big the
rank maybe 500 at most very low rank so
you could be tempted to say well I'm
gonna replace this by low rank model
you do this let's say you do sparse if
you want to so if you do this you
actually put noise in the data right you
replace this by something else so
basically you are the one putting in
extra noise because you're compressing
your data all these advocates is to say
when you do that please don't forget
that you actually put in noise and if
you in this case if you know the first
single value that you threshold that
down to zero in other words if you have
an estimate of the error you made which
you almost always have as a byproduct of
a low-rank approximation that number you
can use it in your in your approximation
to take that into account in a robust
way in other words instead of minimizing
this you minimizing the maximum of this
plus a perturbation and and you run with
that the perturbation is supposed to be
in that set so that leads you to add
simply that's the theory that emerges an
elastic net part where the error is
really the the regression I mean the
that epsilon is that X so this is just
an example where you purposely you add
noise but you should take noise into
account
all right so I'm going to try to give
you a little bit of theory I think I'd
like to touch on globalize robustness
and that will probably be the end but
basically what I want to say is that if
you're facing a supervised learning
problem there is a theory that allows
you to say well what should I do if I
have an uncertainty model and then what
is the result okay so it doesn't work on
any machine learning problem but
actually there is and I'm going to be a
little fast because I want to reach a
certain point here but there is a wide
range of problems from supervised
machine learning where it's
straightforward to apply a robustness
idea these are examples and so basically
what you start with is you say I have
data
it's my matrix and I let a perturbation
model take on and I solve a min max
problem where the max is over the data
theta is the regression coefficient or
classification coefficients okay so
these problems they have there's a
library of things we can do so I won't
go through those because you can do math
like you know if you like it you can do
it but basically here's an example you
know for example if I assume my
perturbation is of a certain type that
essentially each column is perturbed and
the maximum amount of perturbation that
way is bounded and I measure
perturbation by Euclidian norm on each
column so it's a max Euclidian norm it's
a special norm then this is the worst
case thing so basically this number is
exactly the amount of perturbation that
you tolerate under this norm if you
measure perturbation this is very
natural you look at each column the
perturb as vectors so you use Euclidean
norm and then
you look at the worst-case across the
cones so what this is here is an example
just an example of what's known as
globalized robustness so there's a lot
of pushback when you you know you start
talking about robustness you say worst
case there's some people who jump or
freeze
you know worst case what do you mean
worst case is going to be super
conservative right so here the the fear
is that you're being overly conservative
I'm to this I answer in two phases one
is yes you're super conservative if you
give nature too much power then you're
going to be very conservative the other
solution would be not to take into
account nothing about your adversary
about noise and anything you can see
that this doesn't fly as well so a
little bit of conservativeness okay the
other part is this notion of globalized
robustness and I'll start with this
problem as involving you know a
classical machine learning problem and a
bound on the and I'm sorry this is not
theta it should be Omega it should be W
rather it's the coefficient of your
problem it's the decision variable you
can see there's constraints it's not a
penalty in fact there's an
interpretation of that in terms of
globalized robustness what that means is
in globalized robustness what you're
trying to do is not to say okay I'm
going to make sure that things go well
for the worst case over a number of
scenarios and outside this scenario set
I don't care what happens okay so when I
do for example robustly squares I do
this
[Music]
let's say I do this I'll use a notation
consistent here let's say I chosen norm
this is my robust least squares problem
here I'm saying
I want to control the error the residual
for all matrices that are within epsilon
of X but outside that if Z is much
further down from X than Epsilon I'm not
saying anything globalize robustness
what it tries to do is simply to say
outside
I won't control the rate at which this
degrades so it's a rate condition and
you can see that basically if you
control the size of W then you'll
control that rate and so basically when
you see machine learning problems that
involve penalties instead of penalties
that involve constraints like this one
this is penalized this is not a penalty
model it's a constraint model it's less
popular but it's interesting because it
has this globalized robustness
properties it will degrade gracefully as
you have more and more noise more
greater than any other
yes in fact I don't know of much
empirical studies of that but the theory
is that with this you you control the
rate but with the other model you don't
control the rate
all right so finally chance constraints
as you know in machine learning
stochastic models are popular and so you
can do also a chance constraints and the
more or less look like this classical
models either with penalty or
constraints but the message that I want
to leave you with to finish this lecture
is it's simple I believe that you know
there's realistic cases where you have
noise in your data that's pretty obvious
I am a strong proponent of the idea that
whether you use penalties or constraints
the important point is to weight the
different features for example in those
problems here our model essentially
doesn't make a distinction between
features but if your model says okay
your data this part of the data is less
uncertain than that part then those
that's where those models become
interesting because they tell you how to
scale your features basically I guess
that's it
[Applause]
[Music]
now more complicated nominee
investigation Nikolas think you is added
for example that's this suggest that the
vegetation
I see so maybe you're revoking for
example if you talk about nonlinearities
and so on like neural net models for
which you know there are robustness
issues in neural nets I'm not sure how
to exploit the structure of the neural
net to come up with a better model I
think it's quite complicated the it
there are paths where you can but it's
it's it's not that simple I think you
can think in the way of non-linearity
that's one direction but the other
direction that was evoking earlier I
think that's where the most juice comes
about which is exploiting society
information about the relative ranges of
uncertainty affecting different parts of
data that's where this would in fact
does provide better results I'm not sure
if it's in the direction of nonlinear
models so what was the tell you you see
things like this like any of the
examples you've written down the weight
the more popular or this is that those
penalties on W are somehow structural
penalties about the solution yes every
structural penalty like that has an
interpretation as a robustness about the
data in the theory outline here yes it's
a full ik you can recover almost I mean
it's how can we you be exhaustive right
but you take scikit-learn and all the
penalties and you can recover them this
way but of course to me again it's not
necessarily it's it's nice but it's not
necessarily the value the value is going
beyond that and now instace when you
have structural constraints or penalties
it usually means that the uncertainty is
very simple its element wise all the
same all the same amount of uncertainty
are affecting every part of the data
where it's interesting is when you
you have differences in noise affecting
different parts of data that's where I
think the juices and I have not yet
shown examples of that working better
because I have not done it but I'd be
interested if somebody wants to take on
that now Ben is very pensive and I'm
thinking I'm sure you're all very tired
so
[Applause]